so let's think a little bit about the
maxwell boltzmann distribution and this
right over here this is a picture of
james clerk maxwell and i really like
this picture it's with his wife
catherine maxwell and i guess this is
this is their dog and james maxwell he
is a titan of physics famous for
maxwell's equations he also did some of
the foundational work on color
photography and he was involved in
thinking about well what's the
distribution of speeds of of air
particles of idealized gas particles and
this gentleman over here this is ludwig
boltzmann and he's considered the father
or one of the one of the founding
fathers of statistical mechanics and
together through the
maxwell boltzmann distribution they
didn't collaborate but they
independently came to the same
distribution they were able to describe
what's the distribution of the of the
speeds of air particles so let's back up
a little bit or let's just do a little
bit of a thought experiment so let's say
that i have a container here
let's say that i have a container here
and let's say it has air
and air is actually made up mostly of
nitrogen let's just say this has only
nitrogen in it just to simplify things
so let me just draw some nitrogen
molecules in there and let's say that i
have a thermometer
i put a thermometer in there
and the
the thermometer
the the thermometer it reads a
temperature of 300 kelvin
what is this temperature of 300 kelvin
mean
well in our everyday life we have a kind
of a a visceral sense of temperature hey
i don't want to touch something that's
hot it's going to burn me or that cold
thing it could
it's going to make me shiver and that's
how our brain processes this thing
called temperature but what's actually
going on at a molecular scale
well temperature one way to think about
temperature this would be a very
accurate way to think about temperature
is that tempera i'm spelling it wrong
temperature
temperature is proportional to average
kinetic energy of of the molecules in
that system so let me write it this way
temperature is proportional to average
kinetic energy
average
kinetic
kinetic
energy
energy in the system
energy i'll just write average kinetic
energy so let's let's make that a little
bit more concrete so let's say that i
have two
two containers so it's one container
whoops
and two containers right over here
and let's say they have the same number
of molecules of nitrogen gas and i'm
just going to draw 10 here i this
obviously is not realistic you'd have
many many more molecules one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
one two three four five six seven eight
9 10.
and let's say we know that the
temperature here is 300 kelvin and the
temperature the so the temperature of
the system is 300 kelvin and the
temperature of this system is 200 kelvin
so if i wanted to to visualize what
these molecules are doing they're all
moving around they're bumping they don't
they don't all move together in unison
the average kinetic energy of the
molecules in this system is going to be
higher and so maybe you have this
molecule is moving into that direction
so that's its velocity this one has this
velocity this one's going there this one
might not be moving much at all this one
might be going really fast that way this
one might going super fast that way this
is doing
that this is doing that this is doing
that
so if you were to now compare it to this
system this system you could still have
a you could still have a molecule that
is going really fast maybe this molecule
is going faster than any of the
molecules over here but on average the
molecules here have a lower kinetic
energy so this one maybe is doing this
i'm going to see if i can draw on
average
they're going to have a lower kinetic
energy that doesn't mean all of these
molecules are necessarily slower than
all of these molecules or have lower
kinetic energy than all of these
molecules but on average on average they
are going to have less kinetic energy
and we can actually draw a distribution
and this distribution that is the
maxwell boltzmann distribution
so if we let me draw
a little coordinate plane here
so let me
let me draw a coordinate plane
so
if on this axis i were to put speed
if i were to put speed and on this axis
i would put number of molecules
number
of
number of molecules
right over here
for this system the system that is at
300 kelvin the distribution might look
like this
so it might look
the distribution let me just send a new
color
so
the distribution this is going to be all
of the molecules the distribution might
look
might look like this
might look like this and this would
actually be the maxwell boltzmann
distribution for this system
for a system let's call this system a
system a right over here and this system
that has a lower that has a lower
temperature which means it also has a
lower kinetic energy the distribution of
its particles so the most likely the
most probable the you're going to have
the highest number of molecules at a
slower speed let's say you're going to
have it at this speed right over here so
its distribution its distribution might
look something like this
now
so it might look something like that
now why is this one it might make sense
to you that okay the most probable the
the the speed at which i have the most
molecules i get that that's going to be
lower than the speed at which i have the
most molecules in system a because i
have because these on average these
things have less kinetic energy they're
going to have less speed
but why is this peak higher well you got
to remember we're talking about the same
number of molecules so if you have the
same number of molecules that means that
the areas under these curve need to be
the same so if this one is narrower it's
going to be taller and if i were going
to if i were to somehow raise the
temperature of this system even more
let's say i create a third system or or
i get this or let's say i were to heat
it up to 400 kelvin well then
then it would look then my distribution
would look something
would look something like this so this
is if i if i heated it up
heated
heated up and so this is all the maxwell
boltzmann distribution is i'm not giving
you the the the more involved hairy
equation for it but really the idea of
what it is it's a pretty neat idea and
actually when you actually think about
the actual
speeds of some of these particles even
in the air around you the air around you
might say oh it looks pretty stationary
to me but it turns out in the air around
you is mostly nitrogen that the most the
most probable speed of if you picked a
random nitrogen molecule around you
right now
so the most probable speed i'm going to
write this down because this is pretty
mind-blowing
most
probable speed at room temperature
probable
prob
probable speed
speed of
n2
at room temperature
room temperature
temperature
so let's say that this was the maxwell
boltzmann distribution for
for nitrogen at room temperature let's
say that that's let's say we make we
call room temperature 300 kelvin this
most probable speed right over here the
one where we have the most molecules the
one where we're going to have the most
molecules at that speed
i in fact guess what that is going to be
before i tell you because it's actually
mind boggling
well it turns out that it is
approximately 400
400 and actually 300 kelvin is going to
be 422
meters per second
422
meters per second imagine something
traveling 422 meters in a second and if
you're used to thinking in terms of
miles per hour this is approximately 944
miles
miles per hour so right now around you
you have actually you're the the mo the
most probable the highest number of of
the nitrogen molecules around you are
traveling at roughly this speed and
they're they're bumping into you that's
actually giving you air pressure and not
just sp they're actually ones that are
traveling even faster than that even
faster than 422 meters per second even
faster there's particles around you
traveling faster than a thousand miles
per hour and they are bumping into your
body as we speak and you might say well
why doesn't that hurt well that gives
you a sense of how how small the mass of
a nitrogen molecule is that it can bump
at you bump into you at a thousand miles
per hour and you really don't feel it it
feels just like the ambient air pressure
now when you first look at this you're
like wait 422 meters per second that's
faster than the speed of sound the speed
of sound is around 340 meters per second
how can this be well just think about it
sound is transmitted through the air
through collisions of particles so the
particles themselves have to be moving
or at least some of them have to be
moving faster than the speed of sound so
not all of the things around you are
moving this fast and they're moving in
all different directions some of them
are might not be moving much at all
but some are moving
quite incredibly fast so i don't know i
find that a little bit mind blowing